the sunlight down there is incredible
because you get to see animals go about
sort of what they do in perpetual
sunlight in 24 hours general if you have
night time if we've got an instrument on
an animal or it gets dark out you can't
work and so for me I'm a very visual
person a lot of the stuff that we do is
visual looking at whales following them
so to have the constant sunlight in the
summer time it's pretty remarkable
perpetual Sun it's not easier to film in
is this the start cuz it's gonna get and
the crazy thing is like you come out of
your tent and it's 2:00 in the morning
and you have to put your sunglasses on
because it's so bright but due to the
perpetual Sun you get sunburned you have
to put on gobs and gobs of sunscreen the
atmosphere is thinner there and it just
adds an extra challenge you can't put
enough filters on your camera because
it's always so bright it's kind of a
blessing and it's a little bit of a
curse too
yeah I'm confused now at the time
actually I think it's morning the
deceptive thing you don't know it's
after midnight because it's always like
the actual Sun is probably harder than
perpetual night to deal with because to
get routines and patterns into your life
you can be awake at 2:00 o'clock in the
morning it's like a nice warm summer's
day so you end up going for a walk and
suddenly we are routines gone away
whereas winter it's initially a little
bit easier to get into a normal daily
routine double-arrow for comfort an
extra warmth to be able to wake up at 3
a.m. 2 a.m. and it be bright sunlight as
quite an unusual thing but what you see
and what you hear in those hours is
quite special